in a hamdulillah nominee who was time
for stuff you what I would be lying in
churu bien phu SI de winter Yadier
Molina may I didn't lavender lavender or
may give them fella Nadia why should one
everything Allah what the Buddha sure he
can wear eyeshadow and then we'll have
made it up to who water soon indeed all
praise is for the Creator the Exeter a
los han river we praise Him we seek his
help we beg for his forgiveness we seek
refuge with allah almighty with allah
from the evil within ourselves and the
evil consequences of our evil actions
whoever Allah guides who is very path no
force in the universe can this guy him
and what Allah let's go straight to lose
on corn no one can kinda back except the
creator of love I bear witness and open
testimony that there is nothing no one
worthy of any act of worship except the
Creator Allah and I bear witness that
Muhammad sallallahu alaihe so is his
slave servant and final message now note
when we made this declaration we
automatically include not exclude all
the preceding messages that came before
muhammad sallallahu it's just an
interview ISA please Jesus moves are
links are not Moses in reheema ladies
tonight Abraham no one yeah yeah some
additional Isaac we believe it all of
them when we made this declaration we
send peace and blessings on all of them
and we know that this way
life that we live they all call people
to live all of them came with proofs and
evidences to prove that they were indeed
messages from Allah they were Muslims
just like you are here today those who
submit to the love allah and today we
have the living miracle which is the
Quran Tamra free temper move for anyone
sincerely looking for the truth and the
Muslim who's found a trove and now he's
inherent to the Quran and Sunnah
everything is there a law saying in the
Quran yeah you men latina Avila took a
lot haha dr. party he will Hamilton that
11-2 must be move o you who believe have
talked a lot is deep reverence this
consciousness of your maker fear Allah
as it should be feared and die not
except in a state of submission in the
state of this none don't get caught
O'Connor that you're at place you should
be at a time you should be and then one
of the more comes for you and it is over
is too late so it's a wording from the
Almighty from a lot in a state of
submission at all times now Allah knows
we're going to be we make mistakes
that's why the doors of toga repentance
are always open for you to be able to
make a u-turn but we believe we live
between that fear and then holding the
driving force is love we'll go to what
time side too much Oh God is all about
love then you're at the nightclub you're
doing all sorts of things you should be
doing or too much for you fall into
despair too despondent thinking that
your sins I'm the one that a lot it can
forgive it that's not the case so
between fear and hope now here allah is
addressing all mankind yeah you hadn't
asked
gurgaon a comic nursing why him
halloween has out to have about the
victim on each other Kevin and when he
said what the cooler holiday dessert in
the medieval harm in the law and a lake
pukaki ha o mankind be dutiful to your
lord who created you from a single soul
and then from him he created his wife
and then from the bothy credit a
multitude of men and women tested
memories there's no book in the world
there's a no religious scripture there
is nothing I challenge you to look where
the three is identifying himself as the
one who created you this won't even race
put a stamp on him being the owner
creation identify himself as clearly as
it is in the Quran know where else to
look is here and we have a test
ownership and fear Allah hoo hoo new
domain kirito right and do not cut the
ties attention yeah in the Latino taco
loco loco encendida you sleep no matter
where you kill the Omega te la crosse
hula hoop forget first attempt edema my
bad we'd ask the company vp terrible a
lesser than happy honey [ __ ] or
should we both know that
that in bitter Kalugin era lavington
phenom also you must know that the best
of speech is the book of allah and the
best guidance is that of the messenger
muhammad sallallahu lives on his sunnah
and the worst of all affairs are those
newly invented things in the team we're
not talking about so i told i met
elevators microphones no we're talking
about if the province also a lot in
revealeth the prophets doesn't teach it
his companions they did understand it
they didn't have it at their time in the
religion we stay away from those things
his Claire Aslam needs to submit not to
a vet so that's what the messenger of
allah every hobo he was advising the
people calling the people to the simple
message of islam and hearing to the
tenant because you go out to some places
thousand different places of worship
thousand different sects and everybody's
doing it your way this is not murder
king having airway no it's the greatest
weight lossweight so we submit we follow
the movement now i want to talk to you
my brothers and the sisters here today
on three points one is the purpose
understanding this purpose to put the
fuel for the purpose and three sharing
purpose now it's very important that we
now and it started to say many Muslims
would you ask them many of the
fundamental principles of this level
people don't know but we should be able
to understand it because it's very easy
to understand people had all sorts of
in you ask your neighbors your friends
what's the purpose of life most people
don't get asked this question and then
we asked them they have a million in 10
different purposes that nobody knows the
real menace someone might say hey it's
to help humanity it's part but that's
not what if you're someone stuck in a
wheelchair you need someone to push you
around who you help it you can't even
help yourself so is that the general
purpose the ultimate purpose how about
someone says always to have a family to
raise some kids good shout what if
somebody they can't get married where
they can get mary kay cabot divorce
can't remarry is that guiltily purpose
there has to be an ultimate purpose for
everybody and our law tells us in the
Quran what that is woman I held up those
in devil inside you daddy i will do we
hear this ayah i have not a large thing
i have not created the gym and the
mankind except to worship me to serve me
but do we grasp this do we understand
this concept imagine this you have a
company the boss hires you it's going to
be one hundred thousand a week check and
you have to adhere to these guidelines
but it doesn't just stick to the
guidelines at work he wants you to get
it to carry yourself because you
represent the company outside annoying
it up a word so he said look if you
posted some funny stuff on face
I'm gonna get fired because we want you
to have the utmost in matters and ethics
so these twitter posts we're going to be
monitoring those things Facebook same
thing on the job and after John good
moral conduct code that they want you to
stand by you wouldn't have a problem
with that would you you get that hoe
hundred-thousand-dollar check so your
whole life will be around pleasing your
boss your demeanor at all times hold on
someone from the company can check up on
me they might send them at the work at
home to make sure that I'm adherent to
everything I need to adhere to otherwise
I'll lose my town but Allah he has given
us more and he will give us more and
continue to bless us and the Muslims
whole life is having this consciousness
of his maker at all times and living to
please his maker at all times and to
stay away from everything then he told
us because Allah knows best you don't
know that you think a lot of some things
you'd like that's not good for you and
some things you don't like that it's
good for you don't know Allah knows so
when you come to the realization that
indeed is quran is from the greater i
use my intellect i was guided to this
now i hear annihilate in my whole life
revolves now under the umbrella of
certitude of worship and everything that
a lot cause me to is good for me good
for my family good for society now I can
choose now we go back to you want to
help humanity process is there go serve
the Prophet saws on said the best
you are those who are deserving to the
others is a part of the purpose but
don't take the meetings as the ultimate
goal you understand my english is clear
so our whole life we're conscious of our
maker our actions our deeds that they
are pleasing to the one who created us
just like you'll be very cognizant and
aware somehow Allah then pause was
checking up on me they're watching you
in the cameras checking my facebook and
he wants to make sure that i'm
representing the company in the best way
are the ones i defied orful on fire is
in the Hellfire and a lot will put
anybody there unjustly so now we have
our chance and now is William for from
here the purpose also has said that a
man is built on 70 somehow branches the
lowest of which the attention is to
remove an obstacle from the road samala
look at that doesn't have to be bad
that's an act of motion you're removing
something that can have someone in the
road it's going to hurt you you see it
they're known but what you're being a
benefit for Humanity the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam said then the
day of judgment was coming tomorrow not
to see one makes earth green it's in the
same time her go green you heard this rd
teaches us is there the sooner and high
yahoo shoot but will be dead even
modesty is a branch of a man the sister
the prophet
same thing more and more they make it
these clothes tighter to the men you
know they have an agenda is pushing and
now also the modesty for the man can't
have all his private showing what now so
as a monastic for the man to and for the
sister she's not going to eat out with
the tight pants no the hijab knows the
crown or modesty and her behavior her
haha there's nothing being revealed in a
shape of her body and this is an active
valley she's having different moral code
let me add to whom shuttle any man to
another after me gather there to worship
all of these things are the bathtub
beauty also should be clean it's not
looking good for sisters for their
husbands obviously not going out but in
your houses in your places and work your
home's spiritual purity first and
foremost bringing ourselves and all
sorts of [ __ ] again all of the things
that are displeasing to Allah and then
physical purity it's an act automatic
the highest of which is what they're not
alone let alone the toe heel the viewer
I don't visit and then everything to be
to me look now my second pointed out the
goat and I can expound on this but I
think you get the gist now when someone
asks you is last a question what's the
purpose of life and you can see all of
these secondary things that
the things they are most things people
say are good and you'll find them in
this lab but those are a person can feed
look they can be out there donating to
the whole world getting billions and
millions but at the end it wasn't built
on the pyramid theism it wasn't built on
told me they didn't make a dress himself
interest to get out of a class list
maybe on a lot of water in this life but
they do they have shared in the next
life no it's got to be built and they
deem am now the second point each is the
fuel for perfect you look really silly
if you are 12 13 years old and you sink
in Canada want you or now you're a
college student and you're in ninth
grade still there you should be in
college why because we excel in life we
want to go from web belt to the blue
belt and move on you don't want to stay
a while about for the next 20-30 years
do you know you want to excel so what
fuels the purpose climbing the spiritual
ladder deming is incumbent on every
Muslim to seek knowledge to seek
knowledge of the team to put aside time
you're in their car you're not lasting
55 cents JC Katy Perry and all this
other nonsense you are listening to her
appt or listening to a lecture where
someone's giving the tough scene of the
ground or someone's directing you to
what Allah loves to what your Creator
laws explaining it to you the
fundamentals of the team why
more you study this Dean I have a TV
talk show that I do it's called the Dean
show at the end park again we'll have
some bumper stickers please don't forget
to take it right interview so many
different people who come to this way of
life to Islam they've come from a
background of today's unfortunately
Hinduism and one thing they all have in
common that a there was sincerely
looking for the truth and being the more
they looked in to the man-made religions
the more they were unconvinced and the
more they studied is attained aslam the
more game of certainty and uncertainty
that they went against all the odds of
challenges and they ended up accepting
going against culture and society and
the families for what about us we have
the deal and how many of us are ignorant
you ask a person what is this lab what
is the purpose basic things what is that
I gotta khalaby what are you saying when
you put your head down soup and Olivia
added glory be to our Lord people's
heart and fact I translated we don't
know shame on us we have to how much
time do we spend on many of these social
media tools that are out there that can
be used for good but Subhan Allah much
of it what is a use for violence by many
people for the wrong things and then
we've added all of the time that we have
spent on nonsense waiting time you're
not getting paid for that type of Allah
actually a few more latex hinges because
the amount is either going up or down so
it's not fueling your God it's actually
pointed in the heart and is corrupting
us but there's no corruption when you
are spending time the fish in the sea
the birds in the air the whole creation
next to I for the one who's seeking
olives you know this cherry are
synthetic caffeine is not shared along
these two have anything to turn down for
the one who seeks knowledge five minutes
ten minutes in the car you download is
easy down from one destination how many
people travel viton five hours here when
our here throughout the week is added up
10 hours subhanAllah mention every time
in the car do you handle it already
start today you put a CD by CD set
donate sohana lights and power at home
there's a story of its not a thief or
anything is a story about when sheikh
had related that shank on comes into the
house and when he sees all these TVs he
says my town is done here he leaves sao
paulo not to say that the TV is is haram
no but what's coming into TV how many am
i spending time come to cable all this
promise beauty and just a commercials
maybe you get peace TV maybe you get a
good that TV the deep show but the kids
standing just zombies watching all this
jump is destroying them sending these
subliminal messages and it is educating
your children five six seven eight hours
a day you're going to get some peace and
you just told it in front of the TV and
then it comes back to haunt you what did
you do who raised them i'm the DD days
you hon along so the fuel for the
purpose for the amount is M is now
where people have knowledge so dedicate
a certain amount of time daily weekly to
learn the team to learn from people
acknowledge a cool to call me how that
was stuck from lobbyists and occasional
stuff that will be never won before rain
I se this se forgiveness from Allah for
me for us to tacoma seek forgiveness
from allah Purdy he's the most forgiving
this me that how did that was so that
the west of that also stood it has some
awful evil son the third point so we
covered purpose in a nutshell why we be
creative what are we doing here if
you're on the moon you just ended up
popping up on the moon you want to go by
land alone maybe you go here get some
coffee to have some shops there relax a
little bit calm down something if you
don't get to stop there now figure out
what am I doing here why am I on the
boom why are we on this earth Aslam
explains it something beautifully they
start of evidence we talked a little bit
about that and then fueling the Dean the
purpose we need to be purpose German we
need to put fuel in this car otherwise
that's it then we live in for justice
duniya this temporary portal law has
allowed us to take our share to have
this world in our hands but not in our
heart but if we're constantly don't you
know don't you have done yeah that's it
then what we can tune your eyes that's
it we can to me alive and then we're
asleep and then down comes we wake up to
length is too late so now the third
point I want to cover extremely
important once we grab him Rastus Allah
says in the Quran woman a sunoco Amanda
you know volume on us all
all Indian animals they mean and who is
veteran speeches a rhetorical question
no is better in speech than the one
who's better in speech except the one
who follows to allow does righteous good
deeds and says I am of those who have
submitted to my lord so maybe some of us
we don't speak the best of image but
it's our duty dooney the prophet
sallallahu alaihe was some he commanded
to share his message a lot i command
that we are to share the purpose of the
people maybe you don't speak much good
English it's okay maybe some speed but
it's better they don't speak but you can
give a translation of the Quran a
pamphlet about this now we like to get
in with our co-workers have
conversations about this dad football
cricket in my country and everything
under the Sun we've talked about it what
about the purpose of life have you given
the people to proposition how do you
think and reflect share if you care
you'll share for the big show that's
what is therefore you've done all the
hard work and hundred of them is there
but this is not an option it's a
responsibility we need to be the
ambassadors for his team and that's
built under the toe he done put a flag
because sometimes look muslims in the
way deceiving cheating doing things
opposite to the left leg so built on
that the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wassalam said i have not been said
except a perfect good mannered and at
that time at times that can be something
that will
because before used to also as a
corrosion I had to come on a whole
different level and then I haven't seen
this individual like this honest upright
hosted his promises very helpful and
this is an active amanda is facilitating
kindness with people helping people will
serve or not muslim all of humanity but
at the same time there's an obligation
to the best of your ability to your job
and work you have to produce it doesn't
matter does it at the end you say to the
boss say it looked i put in 50 hours
here but did you make him some money
he's going to keep your mouth say get
lost he don't seem that all the work
effort that you put in but look somehow
along Allah is not gonna hold you to
account because of the results of an
effort he wants you to give your best
asset give your best that's what he
expects from all of us to give our best
for this team and this is aspect of that
world so we covered these three points
in the short of the purpose being
Purpose Driven driving that purpose with
knowledge and sharing that person
sharing that purpose so we'll have some
bumper stickers and with it because it's
all intentional you put a bumper sticker
says purpose of life ever wonder you
have to
stickers out there they're green free
take it put it on your car give it to
someone someone is driving and they see
this bumper sticker everything's on a
mobile they go they go to the websites
move on we have a also a 1-800 number
that they call they ask questions or a
recent article watch show that some
Christian minister accept Islam so many
people so many stories and they say you
know what this one I've been looking for
and you come on the day of judgment look
the scales are so hard and say where did
I get this so it is connected back to
just this small little thing you did
some how long the smaller thing you did
so let's get motivated on this Jew mama
here it's the best day of the week we
come to you these reminders lift them
not just go on one year on the other
take give you a few tangible things to
do many of you are probably doing it
already but cutting out some of the
things that are no benefit really going
the simple concepts of the Dean know how
to share it I don't know hey get to our
place where you do know and that goes
back to the second point driving it with
the knowledge and then sharing to the
best of your ability well as us in the
program sending peace and blessings in
Allah Oh manic episode 01 nov yeah you
had latina Avenue solo la mesilla notice
lima on the Bronx was a lot of muscle
along
solid Oliver he added that he Brahimi
from gym the one who brought us this
guidance a la signorina haha will be
ugly rice anybody tired and for that we
had a four-shot even one player Bucky
they do not love him to the Quran all
slaves of Allah Allah commands justice
and doing a good and liberty to Kin Kin
he commands and forbids all shameful
teams immorality he instructs you that
you may remember remember alone and he
will remember you be thankful to Allah
and he will increasingly your Mountain
have taqwa of a lot of consciousness of
your maker at all times and he will
provide a way out of any issues that you
might be having a chemist
alorica
how many that without being rough Manny
rock in a bikini yeah and I would ye
against aliens the game set all gonna be
under d really
sub is michaela the default ozawa sonu
clink of a determination in who yah yah
silkolene you saw that it inherited the
cross at the carwash ella ella es la la
hija whaddaya got a flaw in deserts
merapi sunday belkin thirunal head tuna
with too high in an official film lan
zhu bra him along
Sonny along tell me that Oh
Oh
this
alone
and how do you like me nah Danny kill me
yeah I can ever do I agonist I said all
those who merely him what will hone laga
had a love sonnet lemme Linden 10 haha
so your blog we were having them along
wha
long
sonali saloon